okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
so
i've been doing these q as ever since
the pandemic started
and
i they've been gradually evolving a bit
over time but i just encourage people to
send
questions about anything about how
things work in science and technology
um
and i'll see what i can do to to answer
them maybe we'll talk a little bit later
about some
ideas that we have for changing this up
a bit and see what people think about
those
all right i see we have a bunch of
questions left over so i see one here
why do flies fly around seemingly
constantly with no apparent goal
whatsoever
well
i think i can say more about the
philosophy than the biology of that
the um
uh
flies
i think
um so what is the fly thinking about
well i suppose that there
uh
you know a a very basic question the fly
like many creatures is probably foraging
for food and there are all kinds of
different foraging patterns that
different kinds of creatures use i mean
sometimes there are creatures like i
don't know caterpillars they're famous
for you know they're going to consume a
leaf and they'll you'll see the track of
the caterpillar and it goes in this
curve
where it's trying to sort of consume the
whole leaf
it's kind of a fun thing because you
know you you have to imagine this
question about how do you snake that
sort of path that the caterpillar is
following so that eventually covers the
whole leaf it's kind of the same type of
problem as if you're numbering zip codes
in the u.s from you know from zero zero
zero zero to nine nine nine whatever you
know how do you snake those numbers
around the the us
it's
the mathematically those kinds of things
where you're kind of snaking a curve
through a whole space so called space
filling curves and there are a variety
of different ways you can sort of design
that space filling curve often these
fractal nested patterns are a good way
to do it but caterpillars use a very
junior version of that and i think
different kinds of animals there's a
whole notion of foraging theory which is
this whole question about you know if
you're a creature and you want to sort
of get all the food from a particular
area how do you move around the area to
get all that food it's the same kind of
question if you're a robotic vacuum
cleaner and you're trying to clean every
part of a room how do you do that and do
you like systematically go one line and
then the next line scanning through the
room or do you go like in a spiral shape
and try and cover the room that way
and
so there are these different kinds of
systematic foraging techniques um i
suspect that flies if they are doing
something where they are trying to find
things they may have a simpler technique
that's more of a random walk because if
you say imagine the robotic vacuum
cleaner and it's trying to clean the
room so one thing it could do is just
scan back and forth scan back and forth
make a spiral whatever else another
thing it could do is just randomly zip
around the room
and chances are that eventually if it
zips around the room for long enough it
will find most pieces of dirt that are
in the room now in in fact in that
particular case because there are
boundaries to the room and corners and
things the chance that it will get into
a corner is lower than than if it was
systematically exploring the thing but
uh you know for a force for a creature
that's sort of foraging that's a that's
a possible approach
now an interesting question is
um
even so another reason for for critters
to do sort of random stuff is because
they want to escape a predator it's like
if you always did the absolutely
predictable thing
then you would be very in your predator
just has to learn well if you you know
go to the right of the creature the
creature will go to its left okay so cut
that off and and get it from the right
it's the same kind of thing if you're
imagining some you know ai based robotic
tank or something and like you know when
this happens it always does this
well the enemy can then go and use its
ai system to be smarter than the first
ai system and you know blow up the tank
or whatever
so it's this idea about do something
random and unpredictable is is can be
useful in i mean it's like i don't know
when people i don't know at least in
movies when people are like you know
running away from something and it's
like they run kind of randomly sometimes
run back and forth that doesn't seem to
me to make a lot of sense but if they
sort of ran randomly it would be much
harder for the you know the the thing to
hit them than than if they run uh you
know in a very predictable pattern
so an interesting question would be for
a fly how does it make its randomness
how does it actually how does it in its
brain
how is it i think its brain has
we have like a hundred billion neurons
and i think a fly has only over 50 000
neurons maybe in its brain um i think
that's about the right number for ants
as well um
and uh you know it's got those
complicated eyes it's got these compound
eyes not like our eyes where you know in
our eyes we have a lens where we're
focusing the light
uh to make an image on our retina and
for a fly it has these little armature
things where it's got a whole array of
them it kind of got that idea from
trilobites back in the cameroon period
or something where there's this whole
array of of different sort of tiny
little micro eyes and it's just using
those to to
figure out and when light gets into one
of those things it has the same kind of
photoreceptor at the end but it doesn't
have a focus it doesn't have a lens you
know you don't you don't see flies
wearing glasses well it's kind of a
silly idea anyway but but um it would
not it would be a different kind of
thing was not focusing light in the way
that we are where we're taking the whole
image putting it through a lens in our
eyes to focus on our retina so in any
case the you know from the fly's eye
it's getting some visual information
about the the world and then presumably
it's deciding whether to fly with you
know whether to turn and fly this way or
that way or the other
um how does it figure that out and how
does it make a decision
uh you know to now i'm suddenly gonna
zip left now i'm suddenly gonna zip
right i'm not sure and i think it's an
interesting question how sort of
randomness is generated in the brain of
the fly i did look at this once maybe
25 years ago so i'm not sure if things
have been done in it since then at that
time not much was known about it i mean
it's similar to the question of
uh in biology there are certain kinds of
things that we know kind of what the
source of them is like for example let's
say a heartbeat
or let's say
a um
a walking motion we kind of have an idea
that there are things in our brains that
are kind of oscillating back and forth
it's kind of like a like an electric
circuit that is that has a you can make
an electric circuit that will just
oscillate like in a sine wave and it's
the same general type of thing that's
happening there are many kinds of
neurologic neural processes as well as
chemical processes that will just tend
to have this cyclic behavior
um and that that's that's sort of what
it's often called the central pattern
generator which is the thing that kind
of lets critters walk i mean walking you
know has a very definite periodic motion
you're kind of you know you can walk i
mean even even if your brain is is not
uh you know even if lots of things
aren't functioning properly you can
still successfully walk
for us biped it's more complicated we
have to keep balance and things like
this
but in general the you know legs are
moving um will happen in a pretty low
level in the in the nervous system it's
it's complicated when critters like uh
you know for us bipeds we're like we're
either walking where there's always one
foot on the ground or we're running
where we end up with a you know in the
middle of running you've got sort of the
definition of that is both feet are off
the ground for a little bit uh you know
if you're a quadruped four-legged
critter then you have basically four
modes of walking depending on whether
the legs are going sort of in phase on
the two sides you know right feet
forward left feet back or whether you
have a situation where the right foot is
is
uh
is back in the left and the right
right front foot whether whether the
front and back feet are going in in
together or whether they're going
oppositely and that's the difference you
know walk trot canter gallop type thing
um you know gallop i think the the feet
come
the front and back feet are coming uh in
inward outward inward outward as opposed
to going in phase so to speak
but anyway and and then the obvious
question is if you're a millipede where
there are you know mathematically you
can work out how many different possible
in phase out of phase you know legs on
one side legs on the other side things
happen in the millipede and it's some
astronomical number but in fact
millipedes basically i think have two
modes of motion either where the legs on
the opposite sides are going kind of out
of phase or in phase and i think you can
even see if you you like have a
millipede walking along and you like
like touch it at the back of the
millipede you'll see this kind of wave
going up the legs as the millipede
decides to speed up and it kind of has
to it's it's very much like reminds one
of of kind of the propagation of of i
don't know electromagnetic waves or
something or any of these kinds of waves
where where you know
the the front of the millipede has to
the back of the millipede has changed
and the frontal bead has to change to
agree with that and there's a wave that
propagates at a certain speed as that
fact about the change in speed um kind
of propagates down the millipede so any
case a few thoughts about the question
of flies now now another question would
be you see a fly flying around what is
its goal what is its purpose how do we
find that out
you know we see
some uh famous example of these um what
are these
kind of puffer fish things
that i think they exist in the ocean of
japan among other places
where they'll spend a few days and
they'll they'll make in the sand they'll
make this incredibly elaborate pattern
it looks like one of those mandala
patterns where the sand is all piled up
in this very elaborate way it's kind of
an art form type thing and the the the
little fish will make that pattern it's
a huge pattern compared to the size of
the fish
um and then it'll it'll destroy the
pattern and it's like why did the fish
make that pattern
and you know you might say well let's
use evolutionary biology to try and
understand it maybe the fish is
illustrating that it's a very well
functioning fish and
so mates for that fish should come and
then there'll be a fitter you know fish
children and things from this fish who's
been able to make this amazing pattern
and and you know that's a possible
theory but if we ask the question how do
we know
why the fish made that pattern that's a
very difficult question to answer it's a
difficult question because if we say
why do we humans do what we do it's like
why do i do these live streams why do i
uh
you know why do i
okay if you say why do i eat something
well it's because if i didn't eat you
know i would starve
why do i eat why do i do i don't know
why am i writing some elaborate document
right now about some obscure
uh kind of um very beautiful um
system kind of of a
numerical multi-way system why am i
writing such a document well there's a
whole chain of stories about well i find
it fun and it's useful for this and i'm
learning about that and so on and so on
and so on but i've got this whole chain
of explanations of why why why am i
doing this
and that chain of explanations
ultimately kind of plugs into a whole
sort of cultural story of well you know
we're at this time in history when
things are this thing is happening and
that thing is happening and you know we
understand the value of intellectual
ideas and et cetera et cetera et cetera
so in the end this why why why are we
doing something you know plugs back into
the whole sort of story of our history
and the history of our civilization etc
etc etc for the fish
what is that story we have no idea
and it's you know we can give these kind
of evolutionary biology explanations but
if we say kind of from the point of view
of the fish why is it making this
pattern who knows you could say oh it is
just
a mere reflex of the fish that makes
that pattern
but you know you could say that about a
lot of things that humans do it is a
mere reflex
that
we
choose to um i don't know
uh
write
giant essays about things because we are
merely filling out our sort of reflexive
uh built-in feature of you know
communicate
or something you know you can make up
those kinds of stories but
the the sort of the real answer to the
sort of the the how do we understand the
purpose of the fish for example in the
end the only sense of purpose that we
really understand is the one that we
have and that's tied into our sort of
cultural history and all that kind of
thing so unless we can make that
translation to the fish it's really
difficult to figure that out and i mean
i think we've talked to another one of
these live streams about animal
communication and the difficulty of
knowing even if you can solve the
problem of you know
the the the barking the meowing the the
tweeting the whatever it is um even if
we can solve the problem of the sort of
the mechanical problem of an
understanding of of that we still have
to deal with the conceptual problem of
okay so we're talking to the cockatoo
what are we going to talk about what is
our sort of shared
kind of idea of what's worth talking
about and how things work that we can
kind of plug into and that's a a
difficult problem and it's a problem
that is of relevance if you're
interested in things like
extraterrestrial intelligence and
and things like that what what what do
you imagine is the kind of common medium
that you can talk about
all right we are um
we're descending into philosophy here so
i i'll um
uh i'm only signed up to talk about
science and technology so
um
uh
let's let's move on to another question
here
um it's a question from asa here why
don't we make houses out of some kind of
amber and then carve them
gosh i mean people obviously have lived
in caves at different times in history
and caves are naturally carved typically
by water
um flowing through rock
uh i suppose that you know you could you
could make your own cave and people will
occasionally do that when they make some
bunker somewhere you know you drill out
a bunch of rock
um i think that uh uh when it comes to
sort of the making of a house for
example
the um
the technology of how to do that has
remained pretty constant through human
history although houses get more and
more and more elaborate and more and
more detailed and you know they're
whether it's well you just cut down a
tree and
you know chop it up and and use that to
make pieces of a house or whether you're
making um some kind of cement-like thing
or or whether it's fancy concrete with
very elaborate material science or
whether it's engineered wood that is
kind of wood that's been been treated to
be much stronger or those kinds of
things but those are sort of details i
mean there's a there's some efforts in
modern times to print houses
um so you know to have these giant 3d
printers so i mean the difference
between
you know fundamentally if you're going
to make a plastic thingy
there is both the sort of you can one
way to make the plastic thingy is you
have a mold typically made of metal
and it is the uh and you pour plastic
into the mold and the plastic forms into
the shape that is in the in the gap in
the mold and that's how you make your
your plastic elephant or whatever it is
that you're making is you've made a mold
where there's a where there's a elephant
shaped hole in the mold you pour liquid
plastic into that you let the plastic
cool down and solidify and then it will
be in the shape of an elephant you pull
the elephant out now you've got a
plastic elephant that's sort of the
traditional way from when plastics were
invented in 1930s and so on to um uh
well to today of of making things out of
plastic the concept of injection molding
is a little bit different it involves
you're kind of squirting plastic into
this void into this hole inside this
mold and then you might and then you
take the mold apart so you can get the
object that's in there but so that's
sort of one way of making things another
way of making things is this kind of
additive way of making things which is
how 3d printers work where instead of
saying we'll just have this hole in this
piece of metal and we'll squirt plastic
in there what instead one's doing is one
saying let's build up the plastic just
granule by granule you know heating it
up and each granule is heated up and is
sort of added to the the growing thing
so when you watch a 3d printer do its
work you'll see a print head and it'll
be running around we'll be squirting out
little pieces of plastic and it'll be
gradually running running running around
and gradually the object that you're
building will get bigger and bigger as
as it has things added to it so people
have tried to make sort of printers like
that that print houses and i think
there's a big effort right now to to
have some some things made that way and
you can make all kinds of elaborate
shapes and structures in that in that
fashion um i don't think we really know
what the what the architectural story of
houses will be in that in that form you
know one thing about houses
is that you know people tend to have you
know rectangular shape roughly
rectangular rooms they have rooms with
square corners and so on and uh at times
people have experimented like there was
a chap called buckminster fuller who was
famous for experimenting with you know
the circular house and things like this
my impression is that the nature of kind
of you know it's it's all a complicated
societal thing because most of our
furniture is made to be square-ish
and so if you have your round house so
to speak
it's um uh unless one of the issues is
if you have a round house and you want
to put a piece of furniture against the
wall the curvature of the furniture has
to agree with the curvature of the wall
or it isn't going to fit
if you have a straight wall you can have
a piece of furniture of any length that
is straight and it will always fit
against the wall and so that's a sort of
a problem with it with a with a circular
house and i think you know until you
kind of build the whole infrastructure
oh we're going to have standard shaped
you know houses that are always you know
whatever 20 feet across or something and
we're going to have that curvature and
we're going to have everything fit on
the walls it's kind of tough to have
that kind of thing work
but it is an interesting question to
what extent one can sort of imagine if
one's making let's say houses out of
completely different materials let's say
3d printing them you know what does that
mean one can then build i mean in
traditional architecture people had
become very used to kind of these ideas
of the architectural form and often the
actual original reason why you know
columns would have this or that thing at
the top was for structural reasons when
they were first built in ancient times
um but then people got used to sort of
seeing columns that looked like that and
that was kind of the the familiar and
comfortable form of architecture that
people saw and for a long time kind of
people
it's you know when you see a piece of
architecture that has a particular form
it kind of reminds you of all the other
pieces of architecture you've seen of
that form and so in a sense it's
communicating something to see that
architecture and to see yes that's a
piece of architecture that was
characteristic of buildings in ancient
rome or something like this and it gives
one sort of the the gravitas of of of
thinking about things in ancient rome to
see that this building that some
government building or something was
built in that way
and so i mean that was kind of the the
um people's you know the familiarity of
what we saw from sort of our history in
um uh has been important there i mean
it's similar to musical form that
there's a certain you know certain kinds
of musical forms where people get used
to them through history and they
communicate something culturally which
if you just invent just a random
collection of notes it's not going to
communicate anything culturally because
it's just been created fresh it doesn't
have that it doesn't have sort of burnt
in history associated with it and i
think the same thing is true of
architecture that there's a certain sort
of burnt in history associated with
these particular forms it's also the
case that because we're exposed to
nature and nature has
particular in a sense architectural
forms we have you know trees with leaves
and this and that and the other and so
that's those are common motifs that we
see in architecture partly because those
are things familiar from nature
and if we start saying well let's get
rid of those we don't need all that
ornamental stuff in architecture let's
just have the plain flat wall you know
the perfect you know the perfect flat
thing
that feels very unfamiliar and
uncomfortable perhaps to us because
we're actually used to the idea that in
nature that doesn't happen very much you
don't see a lot of perfectly flat
surfaces perfectly geometrical forms and
so on i think it's a thing you know
maybe 100 years ago or so now people got
very enthusiastic about the idea that
you know let's let's derive architecture
from science let's take these perfect
geometrical forms that we understand in
science let's say that's all we really
need you know a building just has to be
a box and let's just make something that
is a perfect box because sort of science
is telling us perfect boxes are a
possible thing and that's all we
functionally need for the building let's
make it that shape and turns out i think
people don't
particularly
most some people think that's very
elegant other people feel a bit
uncomfortable because they're used to
these forms not just from the history of
architecture but also from nature which
is a lot older than architecture
they're used to certain kinds of forms
and certain kinds of things that are
familiar for how sort of trees manage to
stand up and things like that and yes
with you know steel and glass and
concrete and all that kind of thing you
can make an architectural form that is
very
unphysical i mean in the end it's got to
stand up but those materials are very
strong compared to things that we're
we're used to seeing in in the natural
world um you can make things that are
very sort of anti-physical um but yet i
think people will find them i mean it's
communicating something to do that
and i think that the um so
this question of well if you could make
a building any shape what shape should
you make it
is an interesting question and people
you know in sort of the modern trend in
architecture
is
you know architects always like it when
they can sort of a have a very rather
than just like well some architects like
it to say instead of saying let's make a
thing that fits into the kind of
tradition of this and that let's make
something unique let's just mold the
thing in our own particular way and i
think some architects even
like take some of them like take clay
and mold it in a certain shape and then
let's say let's make the building this
shape and others will say let's take
some mathematical structure sometimes
even ideas of mine from from looking at
the behavior of simple programs and so
on and looking at the kind of
geometrical forms they produce and let's
make a building that has these kinds of
forms now it's sort of interesting
because in in the most basic version of
that of let's take make a science-based
building in a sense that is just has
this perfect geometrical form that's one
kind of thing that's very unnatural in
many ways it's very different from what
happens in nature
in the kinds of things i've studied a
lot with simple programs where you have
even very simple programs that produce
very complicated forms that's actually
the mechanism we think that nature is
using to make those complicated forms so
in a sense by making use of those simple
programs you are taking out the essence
of what nature uses to make complicated
forms and you might be applying it for
some particular purpose with some
particular elaborate architectural
constraints you know i want to make a
carpet with this pattern but the room is
this weird shape and the pattern has to
make sense given that shape well you can
run this cellular automaton rule and
have it adapt to it will naturally adapt
to the shape of the room and make this
make this form for the for the carpet so
to speak and and so in a sense one gets
to evade kind of the the scienciness the
the cold scienciness of geometrical
structures and things by using for
example simple programs you can generate
in a sense the complexity that we see in
nature but with certain constraints that
might be useful for some architectural
purpose and people have tried building
buildings like that's kind of
interesting and i i've kind of always
always wanted to see a building where
the building from the overall form of
the building right down to the detailed
moldings and ornament was all created
with some particular simple rule one of
the features of that is one of the
things that tends to happen in
architecture is there's a question does
the building make sense does do all the
pieces fit together same with the
musical piece or something like that is
there a logic to the whole thing or is
it just well this person just added this
random piece here and a random piece
there and one of the things that's
certainly true of traditional
architecture is that there are these
kind of you know rules you know palladio
was famous for inventing collection of
these um back in mu when was he
uh maybe
when was he about 1 500 a.d i think um i
might have that wrong but um
i'll be embarrassed if that's wrong by a
thousand years but i don't think it is
um but any case the the um
uh the thing that um
uh you know he kind of gave these
principles for you know what the typical
shape of a room should be what the
typical kind of uh aspect ratio ratio of
of height to width of a um
uh of something should be and and so on
um and uh those are and that provides a
kind of a a framework in which you can
kind of construct familiar types of
buildings or possibly buildings that
resonate with the kinds of things that
we see in the natural world but so by
creating a building from rules and
having sort of consistent rules all the
way through it you have the potential to
also have that kind of
logical making sense structure
and that's a sort of an interesting
thing to try to do
but any case the the um this question of
sort of
uh
you know it's it's a it's an interesting
question what
um
you know one one question that is sort
of interesting is this question about as
you look at architecture over the course
of time
and you see buildings that were built i
don't know
let's say 200 years ago and you see
buildings that were built in the 1950s
or the 1960s or the 1970s
it's always a little bit
something when you can say oh yeah
that's a very 1970s building oh yeah now
obviously there were architectural
styles from you know from from much
longer ago
but sometimes there's a certain
some of these styles have lasted better
than others and certainly some of these
ones that
i think wasn't helped by the fact that
the materials
which tended to be used you know
reinforced concrete and things like this
tended to not uh age as gracefully as
some other you know stone or brick or
something like this um but in any case
it's also one of those things that i'm
always amused by that that um
perhaps i shouldn't be but but the the
that um you know some of these very
elaborate architectural forms where
people are saying we're going to use the
latest technology to build this building
in a really arbitrary shape that has
this weird roof that is you know a very
complicated you know uh very complicated
shape
the practical issue that always comes up
is does the roof leak
because you know a traditional roof it's
just
you know it has its little shape and you
know if you go to the uh some parts of
the world the alps i guess you know you
have these much more pointy roofs
because i guess it snows more and
and so on there and you kind of don't
want a bunch of snow sitting on the top
of your roof but if you end up with
something where it's some very very
elaborate shape now i i guess people
have figured out this issue about roofs
leaking by now and now no doubt there
are fluid dynamics simulations that
figure out where rain is going to
collect and how what's going to happen
if the wind of the goes this way or that
way but these are things which which
always have to go wrong before anybody
figures out how to make them go right i
mean it reminds me of a famous story uh
of the um uh talking of architectural
problems the tacoma narrows bridge in
washington state
this was a um this is a story it's a
suspension bridge so you may know that
um you know these types of bridges right
you can you can build a bridge across a
river or something and you can just uh
put it in um you can just have sort of
each piece of the bridge hold itself up
for itself but you can have a suspension
bridge we have two big uh
two big pylon type things at the two
ends of the bridge and then you
basically hang the rest of the bridge
between those two and so when you hang
it you typically you have this giant
cable that hangs between those two
things it's like a piece of string
hanging between you know you hold up two
ends of a piece of string and the string
will hang in a certain shape
and the shape it will hang in is called
the catenary and it's a particular shape
it's a hyperbolic cosine is in the first
approximation is the is the shape it
forms um and it's it's just sort of dips
down and forms that shape and so when
you build a
a suspension bridge you're you know you
put up these two big pylons you you
suspend you have this kind of giant
cable then you suspend the the roadway
or whatever you have from from that big
cable that is in the shape of a category
okay so good idea interesting way to do
it requires you know it's a it's a
interesting engineering thing okay so
there can be bugs so if there's wind
that blows through
you know across the bridge one of the
issues that can happen is that let's say
the roadway
could be like a little bit of it like a
sail you know the wind catches the
roadway and it will push in a certain
direction
well the problem is there will be a
certain resonant frequency so whenever
you have a thing a string something like
that you know you pluck the string
there's a certain natural frequency that
the string will go and vibrate with and
so similarly in the case of a roadway
for example there's a certain natural
frequency associated with for example
the twisting of the roadway or something
like this so the wind's blowing through
and if the gusts of wind are blowing
through in a certain way they will tend
to excite
the um
this natural resonant frequency in this
uh in this roadway and so the bad thing
that happened with that particular
bridge is as the wind blew through there
it started the roadways started just
twisting and twisting and twisting and
people
i think it was a bit of a tourist
attraction because like not every bridge
has a weird kind of you know surfing
type type
appearance and um the eventually one day
needless to say the the the thing
twisted too far and just broke
and so that was sort of after that time
every new design like that gets tested
in wind tunnels or tested with with
computational fluid dynamics and so on
to make sure that isn't going to happen
one of the things i believe um you know
again it's in engineering after
something goes wrong once then people
figure out let's fix that
and then you know after there's been
that bug has happened then let's build a
way to make sure that bug doesn't happen
again but even after that particular
thing i think they're building a road
bridge in in england in this across the
seven river
and um
although they had done testing of the
final bridge they hadn't done testing of
the half finish bridge and so it ended
up getting some nasty wind resonance
type thing and made it uh
maybe it was just an excuse but this
happened when i was a kid i guess and
that bridge was like unbuilt for like a
decade or something and maybe it was
just an excuse of some engineering or
funding issue but it was always said
that was because of the fact that they
hadn't tested for wind resonance of a
partially finished bridge and so they
were they couldn't work on this bridge
because things kept on sort of being
blown around by the wind
all right let's see
ah
all kinds of questions here all right
there's one from slayer here how do
traffic light systems work
boy diversity of questions here
okay so
the basic i mean
you know originally traffic lights were
just on timers it's just like you know
you you um
uh you know you wait the red lasts this
long and then it goes green and then the
cross street you know goes and so on
in some places there were very elaborate
schemes like new york city for example
has this elaborate scheme where where
all the lights turn and you know change
in a big wave going up the avenues in
new york and you can kind of see and
that means if you're going at a certain
speed you can kind of hit all the greens
but there was a time i guess in the
1960s when automated when it started to
be the case that people made more
automated traffic systems i remember
when i was growing up in england i'm
actually even had some interaction with
the folks who were making those um those
automated traffic systems
and what happened then was that they
would have these strips in the road
which would essentially count cars
and it would be like well if there's a
lot of traffic going this way
have the greens stay longer than than if
it's going the other way
than if there's a lot of traffic going
the other way and so they're actually
with these in the end there were these
formulas developed that well first of
all there were these formulas developed
for what the period of reds and greens
should be based on the flow of traffic
in different directions and i'm not sure
that there was very good uh uh you know
the people developed those theories and
they kind of thought well people have
measured this and people have measured
it thought well somebody developed the
theory and i'm not sure how convincing
uh either side of that actually was
but um it uh but but so those there are
formulas based on traffic flow rate for
what the optimal and i i guess traffic
speeds as well and what the optimal uh
traffic light timing is but you know
then people try to invent
um
all kinds of schemes for getting traffic
to flow properly like a a good scheme is
avoiding gridlock so gridlockers you
have a bunch of you have streets
where you'll have you'll have them at 90
degrees so they'll be crossing over each
other and the problem is people are
trying to go you know up the avenue
and which is going in one direction and
then across the cross street and the
problem is if people if the light turns
red but people are stuck in the
intersection then the people in the
cross street can't go across even though
their light has turned green and so
there's kind of like how do you avoid
that kind of gridlock well one very
simple scheme that was invented is you
paint these boxes on the road with
crisscross lines on them and you say
nobody can be inside that box
when when the light is turned the other
color don't enter that box unless it is
clear for you to get out of the box on
the other side and so that was a a
scheme that was invented to try and
avoid that that phenomenon
and then there are other schemes like uh
you know on freeway on ramps there's the
you know one car per green
scheme of of trying to again trying to
space out traffic
maybe i should explain one basic thing
about traffic so
the why do why are there traffic jams
so you know you might ask the question
if you have a road let's say it's just a
single lane road
and
you have and everybody's going along the
road a certain speed and then maybe
there's some thing that's happening on
the side of the road somebody put up a
weird sign on the side of the road and
everybody's turning and looking at that
sign and so everybody slows down at that
point
what will typically happen is as you go
back on the road eventually you will get
a traffic jam and a traffic jam has the
feature so you might think everybody
just slowed down by five or ten miles an
hour so why doesn't the
the chain of cars going further and
further back just slow down by five or
ten miles an hour why is there a traffic
jam why do things get jammed
why isn't it the case that it's just
that that five or ten mile an hour speed
slow down here just propagates backwards
then everybody's going 5 or 10 miles an
hour slower
well it doesn't happen because of an
instability in traffic
what instead happens is that there are
these waves that get produced that have
an instability and the traffic gets
slower slow slow for a while and then it
starts getting into stop start traffic
and then eventually it gets completely
jammed
and that um and the reason for the stop
start thing the ultimate reason for it
is because drivers have a non-zero
reaction time when if they see a car in
front of them slowing down they do not
immediately start to they it takes them
human reaction time at least a third of
a second let's say or longer a few
seconds often to start slowing down
that's why for example brake lights are
an important idea because if all you
were doing was sensing how fast you're
going relative to the car in front of
you it would be you would have to get
pretty close to realize oh that car has
stopped i better slow down but by having
brake lights you kind of have it know in
advance that the car in front of you is
slowing down and then there was the
innovation of i don't know 10 20 years
ago of having brake lights that were
higher up on cars so that even if you
were not the car directly behind a car
that was slowing down even if you were a
car or two further behind you could
still see that the car in front is
slowing down and so you can start to
slow down both of those mechanisms have
to do with reducing the time delay
associated with driver reaction to cars
and fronts slowing down because it's
that time delay that eventually leads to
this instability it's it's a kind of
mathematical fact not totally trivial i
think to derive of of this instability
that develops as a result of driver
reaction times and so
that that fundamental instability is
what leads to uh sort of traffic jamming
and the stop start even though you might
think the traffic will just go
slightly slower
the instead it goes into the stop start
mode
and um by the way it's a funny thing but
but i worked a lot in the early 1980s on
these things called cellular automata
which is these very simple uh
computational rules very simple programs
where you just have a bunch of black and
white squares
and you just say at each step the black
and whites configuration of black and
white squares will be updated according
to a simple local rule
so i i worked on these and and figured
out a lot about how different kinds of
rules work and so on turns out i i had
actually worked a little bit on road
traffic flow for completely other
reasons
and years later it turns out that the
standard simplest model for road traffic
flow is precisely one of these cellular
automata that i studied it's one called
rule 184 and it has the feature that it
has you know pretty nice representation
of free-flowing traffic completely
jammed traffic and this kind of these
waves of uh
of kind of stop start that happen in
traffic it's sort of the minimal model
of traffic flow then there are more
elaborate models of traffic flow that
people have and they they get to be
reasonably accurate these days um i
think the tricky thing about traffic
flow modeling is that it's a sort of
multi-scale thing like you could you
could say where are all of the pieces of
traffic uh you know
you're not going to model every car to
one centimeter accuracy nor do you want
to just say oh well we just have this
number of cars in this part of the
roadway you have to have some
intermediate things actually uh
uh some people at our company invented
some methods for doing um
uh doing a rather nice version of that a
couple of years ago um that involves
using uh using graphs as a way to
to represent different sort of scales of
of traffic flow and so on
one of the things that's really
surprising is how little is known about
the precise dynamics of how cars follow
cars and so on there are just a couple
of examples where people have really
measured uh you know one freeway
somewhere in california where for two
hours people traced exactly where every
car goes i mean there are tons of places
where there are cameras on freeway
bridges or whatever else where they're
measuring the overall rate of traffic
flow um but this very detailed thing
about exactly which car went where and
when did it change lanes and all that
kind of thing there's surprisingly
little data on that and so when people
try and make detailed models of traffic
flow there's just not a lot to go on i
mean these days there's obviously a lot
of information about overall traffic
flow from cell phones and cars
where people are you know connected to
some navigation service and it's sending
back data on on well or even not
connected to a navigation service
actually as well for better or worse um
where it's sending back data on there
are this number of iphones that are
stuck in this traffic jam in this place
and that feeds back into a bunch of
traffic information
um in the end it's uh you know there's a
there's a certain societal good
associated with that because basically
in the end people spend less time in
traffic jams because the routing systems
can figure out you know how to how to
send cars to places where there aren't
traffic jams and that's that's
presumably good for people i mean it's
an interesting question is is when you
have a traffic jam for example um
is there any way to to break a traffic
jam is there any way let's say there
were self-driving cars in the traffic
jam and
associated with that that sort of
traffic situation is there a way to have
like seed cars somewhere which drive in
a particular weird way and which caused
the traffic jam to be broken up i i
suspect not because i suspect that the
instability of traffic jams is an
instability that will happen
and there's no there's no obvious way to
to fix it now of course there are things
people do
like for example if it becomes the case
that there are enough self-driving cars
that stop being lanes for self-driving
cars and so on they will have completely
different characteristics in terms of of
this issue about driver reaction times
and so on one way they'll have a
different characteristic is that
self-driving cars can communicate with
each other i mean it's it's like you
know drivers don't really communicate
other than by seeing brake lights and
things like this
drivers are not unless they're truck
drivers using using radio and things
like that but then that's a different
kind of thing and not at this more
detailed level but um the uh you know if
they're
this idea that you can have autonomous
cars which are really directly
communicating where that car where the
car you know
uh 30 cars ahead is saying i'm going to
make this change and then then that
propagates to cars far back and
potentially there you can imagine i
think it will work to have you know cars
zipping through at high speeds where you
don't have this phenomenon that's the
result of human reaction times of having
traffic jam formation
but this question about uh
sort of how do you optimize i mean in um
you know what's the optimal way to set
up traffic timings i would say there's a
certain amount of knowledge about that
although as soon as they're autonomous
cars and particularly communicating
autonomous cars all bets are off nobody
there's no theory for that all of the
work that's been done in traffic
engineering tends to be based on these
models that have been developed over the
course of time where people have
gradually tweaked the models to
accurately represent traffic behavior
and it's a bit different in different
parts of the world where people have
different conventions about you know how
much do you how aggressive are you as a
driver and that has an effect on on the
on the effective
on the on the parameters for traffic
flow and so on and so you know you can
expect that there are different dynamics
i don't know the details but but i'm
sure in different parts of the world the
traffic light timings are differently
set up because they're different
expectations about you know to what
extent will people try and run through
yellow lights and to what extent will
this happen and that happen and so on i
always found it interesting that um
you know i grew up in the uk where the
traffic light story is different like
for example when it goes from red to
green
in the u.s
it just goes red and then boom it's
green everybody's going in the uk it
goes red to yellow to green
um actually it goes
my gosh it's too long since i've been
there i think it's red and yellow at the
same time is that right yeah i think
it's red and yellow at the same time and
then green um but uh you know
back in the day people used to say
that's the the yellow is when you put
your car in gear for a stick shift car
um and uh and you're sort of getting
ready to go and then it's go and i
suppose i don't know whether it's a sign
of different national character that um
in the u.s it's just it's red and then
boom it's green everybody goes um
whereas in the uk it's like well get
ready to go and then go i don't know
let's see
oh my so many questions here
um
okay
do i prepare any of these answers no i
prepare nothing here i'm just uh
look at the camera and um and talk so i
i apologize if things are are
more scrambled than they should be
although the thing that's been great for
me about doing these live streams is i i
i think i can measure that i have become
a better explainer of things as a result
of doing this
um
okay let's see we've got another one
here from gist
how are the magnetic north and
geographic north poles related
well
so okay the earth spins on its axis
and it's
it changes the speed at which it spins
slightly and that's why there are leap
seconds and all kinds of weird things
like that but fundamentally the earth is
spinning on its axis
it's its axis is 23 degrees away from
the you know it's orbiting around the
sun and its axis is tipped 23 degrees
from the direction in which it's going
and the plane of the ecliptic in which
it's going around the sun and that 23
degrees is what leads to our seasons and
a bunch of other effects about about the
earth but the the axis on which the
earth is turning that's remained well it
remains almost in a constant direction
it processes it's called the procession
of the equinoxes that's at least the
primary effect it moves slightly it
turns around slightly and that's a
23 000 year procession period i think um
so you know the ancient stars uh
recorded by you know
hipparchus or ptolemy or somebody did
look a bit different from the modern
stars because of procession of the
equinoxes um but fundamentally the earth
is rotating on a definite axis okay
that's that's the rotation of the earth
then the question is what about magnetic
field of the earth
so
when we have a compass a compass has a
uh you know it's a it's a bar magnet and
the bar magnet has what's usually called
its north pole and what's usually called
its south pole those are just names for
the different
the magnetic field is going in a
different direction for that bar magnet
and the magnet is attracted towards the
the sort of corresponding pole of the
earth's magnetic field so i should
explain
the the the earth acts like a giant bar
magnet so a bar magnet has what is about
how does a bar magnet work inside a bar
magnet has a bunch of iron let's say
it's an iron magnet not a rare earth
magnet
iron atoms which are all lined up in a
certain way
and it is a feature of iron atoms that
they have a certain magnetic moment they
put they are like tiny tiny bar magnets
and a piece of magnetized iron all those
little tiny atomic bar magnets are all
lined up and so what happens is the
magnetic field
has it it's aligned in a particular
direction it goes out from you know
let's say from south to north and then
comes out of the magnet kind of makes
this big loop and then comes back into
south again the rule for magnetic fields
is every magnetic field at least if it's
a static magnetic field not changing in
time every magnetic field just has
closed loops of magnetic flux
and that means that for example when you
put iron filings around a magnet you'll
see they will they will collect in the
directions of these of these magnetic
field lines it's the feature of
magnetism that magnetism magnetism
always has closed-loop field lines when
you're dealing with the electric field
electricity when you're doing an
electric charge it works very
differently an electric charge has the
electric charge produces electric field
lines and they all go outwards in a kind
of hedgehog shape from the electric
charge so they all start at the electric
charge and then all go outwards you can
have an electric dipole where you have a
positive electric charge and a negative
electric charge and then there'll be
some electric field lines that go from
one charge to the other than others that
form that same kind of loop going around
the outside so to speak one feature of
magnetism is that so far as we know
there are no magnetic monopoles there
are no magnetic charges so the smallest
magnetic thing you can get is a magnetic
dipole something like a bar magnet or a
very microscopic bar magnet like one of
these atomic bar magnets that is an iron
atom in in in what forms a a
lump of magnetized iron okay so that's
that's sort of how
so the earth's magnetic field is more or
less like what you would get from a
giant bar magnet
how does the earth end up having a
magnetic field
it has to do with the liquid core of the
earth
and it's believed that oh i should
explain another thing
uh
one way to produce some okay i should i
it was i was jinxed by somebody saying
that these explanations were were clear
and and uh initially well thought out i
forgot a piece of this
so
one way to make
a
magnetic field
is from let's say the elementary
magnetic
dipoles of something like an iron atom
another way to make it which is actually
also related is from uh an electric
current so if you have a loop of wire
that loop and you have an electric
current going around that loop of wire
that means there are electrons basically
moving through that loop of wire moving
charge around that loop of wire then it
is a feature of electromagnetism that
you get a magnetic field and the
magnetic field kind of has its field
lines going up through the loop and then
coming around the outside and back
through the loop again so so that's how
a typical way you make an
electromagnetic is with a solenoid and a
solenoid is just a coil of wire that can
be it's just coiled around in a big
spiral and um a big big it's just wound
around some core and when you put an
electric current through the solenoid
it's all kind of going in the same
direction all the loops are going in the
same direction and it will produce a
magnetic field that is going through the
solenoid in the direction at 90 degrees
to the the direction of the loop
so okay so
moving electric charges or electric
currents produce magnetic fields
you can think about that being the way
that a magnetic field is made
well at least at the level
of the electrons going around the
nucleus in an iron atom there is also
another effect which is the electrons
themselves have an intrinsic magnetic
moment which you can't really think
about as the result of a circulating
electric charge it's an intrinsic
feature of electrons that they have this
magnetic field
and not something that comes from
circulating charges
and that's that's ultimately where the
um uh
well where lots of magnetism and
magnetic materials comes from but so
anyway one source of magnetism is
circulating electric currents okay in
the liquid core of the earth
there are thought to be circulating
electric currents
and they're thought to be what produce
the um uh the magnetic field of the
earth
and it's kind of like there's a big loop
of current going around in the earth and
that's producing this big magnetic field
that's like a big bar magnet or like
what you would get from a solenoid
and that the the um
the the so the one question is if it's a
bar magnet what direction is the bar
magnet in
well you might say the bar magnet might
be aligned with the with the rotation
axis of the earth but it isn't quite
it's a little bit off i think it's right
now about in the the north magnetic pole
of the earth is somewhere in um in
northern canada i think it's like in
baffin island or someplace like that
these days um and the north magnetic
pole
is
that's the that's the the earth's
magnetic field is not exactly a pure bar
magnet field but it's a pretty good
approximation and it's as if that bar
magnet is pointing up into northern
canada not precisely the north north
rotational pole
um so one thing that happens is the
magnetic poles of the earth the magnetic
field of the earth actually changes with
time as those currents and the mantle
shift around
um the uh
the the magnetic uh pole of the earth uh
moves around that it moves a significant
amount i mean in a century it will move
a lot it will move enough
that um you really have to pay attention
to it if you have let's say land records
that based on magnetic information i
think in it's not very many centuries
ago that magnetic pole was somewhere in
europe and then the pole has even
flipped around so the north magnetic
pole was even in the southern hemisphere
back in the day and one can tell that by
looking at rocks that were that
solidified at a certain time in history
and you can see that their magnetic
fields were that when they had a when
they generated a spontaneous magnetic
field when they solidified that it was
in a different direction and that
spontaneous field will have been
determined by the magnetic field of the
earth at the time they were formed
so magnetic magnetic poles of the earth
move around a bunch
and presumably the reason this happens
is in the in the liquid core of the
earth
um which is where you get to if you just
drill down maybe 50 miles under the
crust of the earth you get to the liquid
mantle of the earth um there are when
what happens is
there are places
where
uh you have convection currents so
convection is the phenomenon
okay so so for example in
when you have air for example
um
when you have hot air it has a lower
density than cold air and so hot air in
a sense floats on cold air
but if you suddenly heat up some air
down here and it's below some colder air
that hot air will want to go up and kind
of float on the colder air it will want
to rise so the hot air rises the cold
air because it's heavier than the than
the hotter air it'll want to sink so you
you get this phenomenon where the hot
air is rising the cold air is sinking
and but then of course
the total amount of air has to remain
the same so when that's happened you
still have to have this loop as the air
cools down or whatever if it was hot air
and it sank then it cools down and then
as it
as it or it heats up again let's say if
you're heating it from underneath let's
say it
it fell down because it was cold then it
was heated it got hotter again then it
goes back up and you end up getting
these cycles these convection cells as
they're called that form where there's
hot air rising cold air falling and you
get these definite cells you can
sometimes see these kinds of things if
you're if you're heating some fluid
you'll actually see convection cells
where there are regions where the the
areas where where the fluid is coming up
and then going down again actually
you'll get even in very bizarre cases
you'll see rocks that well the
convection cells tend to be these kind
of hexagons that pack together and at
least when when the when the rate of
convection is sufficiently slow that
it's very regular and laminar and um
doesn't have kind of complicated
turbulent behavior um and sometimes
you'll even see that in rocks you'll
have these these um what are they called
devil's causeway type formations where
you have these hexagonal shaped rocks
that were presumably formed by these
kinds of convection cells
but in any case that's the in the mantle
of the earth there are presumably
convection currents and convection cells
and presumably it's the it's the
electric currents associated with those
convection cells that lead to the
formation of the magnetic field of the
earth and those convection cells
gradually move around as a result of
fluid motion in the center of the earth
and that's presumably why the magnetic
field of the earth moves around
so that that's
of course it's not quite as important
these days because people tend to
navigate not with magnetic compasses but
with gps and so this sort of correction
between true north and magnetic north
that people are always concerned about
like you know when you would set a
compass you would have to set the
correction between true north the actual
north associated with the rotation of
the earth and magnetic north associated
with the position of the north magnetic
pole of the earth
um
let's see
um
my there are a lot of interesting
questions here
um
i'll try a couple more here
there's one from oven how come oil is
deposited in arctic regions
oil is deposited everywhere
you know what is oil
oil
so
back in the carboniferous period
when was it
uh
300 million years ago maybe that order
is that right roughly that a few hundred
million years ago
um
before dinosaurs
the carboniferous period was a time
when plants
suddenly appeared
on uh you know in in the um on land
and they were uh they were sort of a
super good idea at the time and so
plants trees whatever covered the earth
um with uh you know with this all of
this very uh lush vegetation
and i think there were
there started to be critters like
dragonflies and things i think they were
around even at that time and you get
this kind of nice vision of the
carboniferous forest so to speak
but
uh and um even the name carboniferous
carbon bearing um is kind of an
indication of what's coming because what
happened is that all of that lush
vegetation that existed at the time when
when plants discovered that they could
grow on land before that there'd been
plants in the oceans algae and things
like that but the sort of mechanism of
of how you succeed in being a plant on
the land and doing photosynthesis and
pulling water from the ground and all
this kind of thing all the inventions
that had to be made to make plants work
on land that suddenly happened in the
carboniferous period and because there
wasn't sort of a lot of competition for
resources there were just a lot of
plants on land on the earth
those plants ended up getting fossilized
they ended up getting kind of crushed
into um
in rocks
and the all of the the stuff the carbon
and so on that had existed in those
plants all the complicated hydrocarbon
molecules that those plants had made end
up turning into as they get crushed by
pressure in rock they get they turn into
oil and so that's what makes these oil
deposits now over the course of
geological time those oil deposits get
covered by things that get covered by
things etc etc etc but kind of any place
where there was land
in the carboniferous period you can
expect that there will be kind of
crushed
uh plants that will have potentially
turned into oil
now the um
then the question is how deep is it
uh how can you find out where it is
all those kinds of questions and this
question of sort of how much oil is
there in the world is a difficult
question and i remember people saying i
know 40 years ago or something oh
there's only this amount of oil in the
world it's like do you really know that
and well no actually because you know
you it could be that there is oil but
it's much deeper or it's or it's much
more enmeshed with rock um you know
sometimes there'll be actual reservoirs
of of liquid oil um and sometimes it'll
be very much in you know sort of uh
kind of inv in porous rock there'll be
it'll be very sort of interwoven with
the structure of the rock there'll be
little pieces of oil but they'll be sort
of very much in the rock and you have to
you have to kind of uh squash the whole
thing to get to get it out so to speak
and so it's this question of sort of how
much oil is there
well the the you know it was all made in
a fairly limited period in the
carboniferous period
and so there's sort of a a you know
there's some knowledge from from that
but this question of how much oil is
there where is it how deep is it um
that's not an easy question to answer
and there's a lot of effort that's been
put in over the years people looking for
oil
and you know part of the strategy is you
drill a hole here you drill a hole here
you see whether there's any oil down
there you drill a hole a certain depth a
mile down whatever else it is you you
figure out is there oil there and then
you say what's the chance that if there
wasn't oil here that if i drill another
hole 20 miles away that there will be
oil there and there's an elaborate kind
of theory of so statistical theory in
fact we're just adding in the latest
version of language we're adding this um
uh this whole area of spatial statistics
is getting well developed
and it's kind of it's kind of
interesting because there are ideas and
spatial statistics that directly come
from from mining and so on there's a
thing called craiging which was invented
by a an engineer a mining engineer who
is interested in gold deposits and it's
a way of sort of giving you an estimate
of what the density given that you've
you've drilled certain holes in certain
places and you've found something you
haven't found something it's a way of
estimating what the likely density of
the stuff you're looking for is in
places other than where you actually
drilled the hole but this is kind of a a
very much a story where you can expect
to use machine learning and all kinds of
statistical techniques to say given that
you drilled a bunch of holes what's the
chance that you will actually get hit
oil strike oil or something um in a
particular place uh
or
based on based on the holes you've
drilled and so on and there's a there's
both an elaborate uh kind of geological
theory and elaborate financial theory of
you know how many holes do you drill and
how much does each hole cost and what's
the chance you know how deep should you
drill them etc etc etc but that's been
kind of a strategy but it's it's hard to
know
what the eventual answer to how much oil
is there it tends it is probably the
case that there is more oil it's deeper
it's harder to get out it's more
expensive to get out it's sort of a
complicated thing but the the question
of why is there oil in a particular part
of the earth
it's well because most places on the
earth there was once a carboniferous
forest and it got squashed into oil and
there are details about whether the oil
is really formed then it depends on the
geology and that's why oil companies
employ a bunch of geologists to uh to
figure out you know what's the
likelihood that in this particular
geological formation there will be oil
formed and will the oil be gettable out
and will it have mixed with the rock in
this way or that way um and so on i mean
i remember many years ago i once
when i was much younger i once did a
consulting thing for an oil
oil instrumentation company and um so i
i learned a certain amount about the
problem of of how oil and water mix in
porous rock and the question of of just
how uh what what you would need to do
and in fact i did come up with some some
ideas which i don't know whether they
were ever implemented about how you
could enhance the um i've always felt
that um perhaps unreasonably that my
small contribution to enhancing the rate
at which you could get oil out
was
was vastly exceeded any possible oil
that i would ever use in my lifetime um
but i don't know if that's a if that's a
good calculation or not but any case the
the um
i mean it's a general rule that
you know countries with bigger land area
end up with bigger mining assets
um just because it's just a pure
statistical question you know if you
have a giant land area australia the us
russia whatever
you know you have these big land areas
you'll tend to have uh you know there'll
tend to be more stuff that was buried
somewhere there and one of the confusing
things
uh i would say probably more so well
particularly for minerals is this
question of you know somewhere there
will be tellurium buried somewhere there
will be europium buried somewhere there
will be gold
and somehow in the formation of the
earth there were all these different
deposits of these different things where
for whatever reason as the earth
condensed and i'm not sure how well
understood this is the you know these
particular materials concentrated in
particular places and now you know
there'll be a city in colorado that's
named after you know i don't know
telluride or something or or molybdenum
city or whatever that's named after
particular minerals but that happen to
exist at that particular place in
colorado let's say um and so i think
that that's uh
you know that's a that's an interesting
phenomenon there's a sort of collecting
effect and i'm sure that happens to some
extent with oil um but uh oil is is not
uh you know its origin is organic and it
was it was from the success of plants on
land
um
yeah i was going to say
uh
the um
today we've had all kinds of interesting
questions and i've only got to a small
fraction of them but i would be
interested in people's feedback about
ways that um
uh this series might evolve i will point
out that all the previous versions
previous uh episodes of this are up on
the web and there's a nice website maybe
somebody can paste it in chat um where
we've run all these episodes through our
uh video
on audio processing system and that
means that we've got word clouds of uh
the top words said so i'm sure that the
last few last few minutes oil will be a
big word that shows up there um as uh
and so you you can you can tell a little
bit what what what i've been talking
about in these different episodes and
they're also some actual questions which
are listed there and so if you're
interested in finding things that
i might have talked about in the past
it's a good way to do that i'm kind of
trying to always talk about something
new and different each time
and
i think
the diversity of questions is very high
the space of possible questions is very
large so in a sense it's easy to start
talking about different things but i
would be interested in feedback about uh
suggestions about how this series might
evolve i might say that i have been
doing i've been doing this on on fridays
at this time on wednesdays alternating
between different weeks i've been doing
a series about q a about um a history of
science and technology and also q a
about business innovation and managing
life
um
and uh i'm i'm trying to fit in more
different kinds of things but i also
have a lot of other activities um i also
have live streamed a bunch of um the uh
well a bunch of other things we've we've
live streamed like yesterday i i live
streamed a discussion i was having with
a physicist um
uh
namely lee smallin um and that was kind
of a different series and we've also
been live streaming a lot of our working
sessions working on physics project and
also working on uh software design and
uh
and those kinds of things but i'm i'm
thinking about uh a variety of other
kinds of live stream things that i might
do
in particular i write quite a lot of
pieces
for my writings kind of blog like thing
and
i've realized that i don't actually
give talks based on the things i've
written there and i don't specifically
answer questions based on the things
i've written there some of them are
somewhat technical but many are not
and um i think i may start a bit of a
series um kind of talking about the
things that are in those posts uh maybe
even basically i've we've made podcasts
from some of those posts and maybe i'll
even do sort of a reading of the post
followed by q a about about the post
um and the the reading will turn into a
podcast and so on um but so i'd be
interested in people's feedback about
hey is this a good idea is this a bad
idea um what uh uh i'm uh i
it's been the fact that i even started
doing these science and technology q a's
which i found well i found fun and
i found really interesting to do um the
um
this was a very coincidental thing
because i figured when the pandemic was
starting i knew there were all these
kids who were out of school and i sort
of had heard from some some people oh
these kids have nothing to do and uh you
know they they need content of various
kinds and so i was like okay well i can
at least
try and answer science and technology
questions uh fun for me hopefully
educational for kids and that's how this
series got started
um
let's see
uh
well i think probably we should uh
wrap up a moment here is that anything i
can
see here that we might um
you see there are questions here that
that are um
uh
coming in let's see
um
the uh
all right there's a question from from
william here let me try and see if i can
do this one
this is a slightly technical question
could i explain what eigenvalues and
eigenvectors are and what you do with
them
okay
so let me give you
an example
so let's say
you have
um
a bunch of
uh
let's say websites
or just places
and they're connected
by they're connected by you know links
and websites roads between places things
like that
you can form a mathematical graph a
network that says
this
this
this thing
this this
sometimes you call them states because
they you can represent the state of a
system by a particular node in this
graph
is connected to another node in the
graph it's connected to other nodes and
so on you form this network okay
so question would be
if you start off
a if you just put down if you start
people off at certain websites you you
randomly scatter people across websites
and then you say let me now have people
follow all the links from that website
and they go to other websites or same
thing with places you know all the
people start in that place and they all
they you know they randomly go down the
roads from that place and they get to
another place and so on so the question
is if you keep doing that
and you keep let's say having these
things randomly run around on this on
this graph
where will things collect
will it be the case there might be some
place where everything collects in that
place there might be another place where
everything is gone from that place
so what you can think of is as you
successively sort of iterate you go to
look at sort of more and more places
where more and more where does it
collect that
uh the the sort of the thing it collects
is uh this is one way to explain it is
is is the largest eigenvector so you can
you can think of uh you can think of it
just to making a vector a list of
numbers
that correspond to how many people were
there at each of the nodes of this graph
and as you keep iterating sort of
running people through the graph
eventually people will collect in a
certain configuration and that
configuration
is um
uh is is one of the eigenvectors of
well of the graph or of the matrix that
represents the graph okay let me explain
that
so um okay vectors
often people think about vectors as
being you know a direction in space or
you know some base and then some
direction in space but at a very simple
structural level you can think of a
vector as just being a list of numbers
it's just you know let's say if it's a
it could be a three three vector which
is a list of three numbers or it could
be a a ten vector that's a list of ten
numbers or whatever else you can think
of those numbers as corresponding to
coordinates of a point let's say in
three dimensional space if there are
three numbers or you can just think of
it as a list of numbers
so you can think there's a there's a
list of numbers okay what happens if you
have a list of lists of numbers
well you can arrange those if you want
to in a two-dimensional grid but a list
of lists of numbers you can just think
of as well it's a list of versatile
numbers but it's also often called a
matrix
a matrix is this kind of array of
numbers a rectangular array of numbers
you can think of it as a list of lists
of numbers
okay so what do what's the point of
matrices well matrices are useful just
as lists of lists of numbers that's a
that's a convenient thing to have around
like that list of lists of numbers might
be
oh i don't know let's say each
each row represents
uh each sort of inner list represents
the coordinates of a point in
three-dimensional space
then you might form a matrix by just
having a collection of those of
essentially those vectors that might be
one interpretation of a matrix
okay there's an important interpretation
of matrices which was the early one from
they were invented by a chap called
arthur cayley in the 1870s i guess
um
the although they're sort of an obvious
idea but they hadn't come up before that
time but in their original invention
they were invented for reasons very
different from these kind of structural
reasons of just whole arrays of numbers
so instead
they were originally invented because
of a kind of mathematical setup so i
mentioned that a list of numbers like
three numbers could represent a point in
three-dimensional space
so a question is if you want to
say how do you you've got a point in
three-dimensional space and you want to
uh let's say rotate that point
you've got this this position in
three-dimensional space relative to some
origin you want to rotate that position
uh by some angle you want to sort of
rotate it um i don't know 30 degrees and
the such and such direction
okay
what does that rotation do
to
the um
uh to the vector to this list
of coordinates of the original point how
do you make that transformation
okay so there's a trick
that transformation can be represented
by a matrix and that matrix in the case
of three-dimensional rotations is a
three by three matrix and what's going
to happen is that three by three matrix
there's a mathematical operation that
you do where you take that three by
three matrix and apply it to this vector
of length three and get out another
vector of length three
and that particular operation it at
first seems kind of unnatural but what
you do is you take the matrix which is a
list of you can think of it as a list of
lists and what you do is the first
the first row the first list first in a
list you take that in a list
and
you basically combine it with with all
the elements in this vector that you're
trying to transform
and then that gives you one result you
take the second row you combine it with
all the elements in the in the vector it
gives you a next result then the third
row and that gives you another result
those three results
are the transformed version of the
vector
how do you combine
the um
the elements in a particular row of this
matrix with the elements in this vector
so there are three elements in one of
the rows of the matrix there are three
elements in the vector let's say what
are you going to do to combine them well
you form so-called dot product scalar
product and what you do is you simply
take those two lists and you multiple
you you take each element take the first
element of the of the thing from the
matrix first element of the thing from
the vector multiply them together get a
result do the same thing for the second
one the same thing for the third one
then you add up all those results
so
maybe i've been using our wolfram
language too long but uh to me i just
think of taking those two lists and you
literally multiply them together and
then they will element-wise multiply and
then you take the result of that and you
find the total of that and that's the
result okay so that's sort of a
mathematical trick
that that you can take this matrix you
can there is a matrix so-called rotation
matrix
that uh
you can construct that represents a
rotation through a certain angle and
whatever vector you feed it
it will it will take and you do this
operation i just described this matrix
product operation um the um uh you
and then you get out another vector and
that other vector will represent the
result of rotating the the point in that
first vector by whatever angle you
specified
and so rotation matrices are one example
of a three by three matrix but you can
put whatever junk you want into that
into that
into that matrix
so
one of the questions is
for many kinds of junk that you can put
into that matrix it will be the case
that the matrix
times
this
vector
will produce something which is
not necessarily that vector itself but
that vector multiplied by some constant
so it's as if that matrix okay so if the
matrix was the identity matrix the
identity matrix let's say 3x3 identity
matrix is just 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 zero one
that means that in the first row when it
combines itself with a vector it picks
out just the first element of the vector
so that becomes the first element of the
result second row picks out the second
element that becomes the second element
and so on so the identity matrix just
keeps a vector and makes it and just
produces the same vector again if you
multiply a vector by an identity matrix
you just get that same vector back again
okay so there's sort of a generalized
version of that which is what if that
matrix instead of producing the exact
same vector again produce something
which is a constant multiplied by that
vector
so that's the case where what one says
is that constant is the eigenvalue is is
a
that that um
that constant i i'm sorry i'm
let me be less confused so you for a
particular vector
given a matrix there will be a
particular set of vectors which have the
property that the result that you get by
multiplying by the matrix is just a
constant times the vector that you put
in the vectors for which that's the case
of the eigenvectors the um uh the the
the um
uh the the constants of the eigenvalues
you know i'm i'm not sure this is the
best way to explain this it may be
better to try and explain this
geometrically but let me say the sort of
the big picture is
eigenvectors are sort of things you get
when that represent
when you do a transformation you sort of
get the same result after you do the
transformation as before so the thing is
i was explaining about all these things
sort of moving around on a graph what
happens there is
when when things have been going for a
long time
going for even longer doesn't make much
of a difference
so in a sense what's happening there is
that you're seeing the eigenvectors come
out as a result of it's it's just sort
of the thing has happened for a long
time and so it's it's reached this point
where that is the result of the
transformation and applying
transformation again that is having time
run even longer doesn't make a
difference and that's kind of the big
picture of eigenvectors is this what you
get
as where where it no longer changes when
you apply this operation
and so for example
the um when you look at um
uh something much more complicated which
is something like i don't know you've
got some drum and it's a certain shape
and you play the drum and you ask the
question under what circumstances do you
does the shape of the drum uh correspond
what are the possible sort of shapes
that the drum can take on while being
consistent with the fact that the that
the drum head is is sort of locked down
on the on the edges of the drum and
those shapes are often called the eigen
modes of the drum the the shapes that
you can take on that are consistent with
these boundary conditions and are
consistent with the equations that
describe the structure of the of the
drum those are the eigen modes the the
uh um there are also
uh eigen values which are
which correspond to the frequency of um
uh of of that particular vibration of
the drum
you know i shouldn't have taken this as
as my as my last that'll be easy
question because this this question it's
a lot easier if i was you know typing
this into orphan language it would be a
lot easier to explain this um and i i
think i'm um uh so that this is this can
be considered a a um
an experiment in my effort to explain
something which is not actually very
naturally explained in words um in words
but so hopefully that gave some sense of
what um uh what eigenvalues and
eigenvectors are
there are lots of
um
lots of things to say to that
all right um
i'm going to wrap up now
and uh
uh please remember
um
uh do do tell us your feedback about
rejiggering uh
these um these live streams uh you can
send it to outreach at wolfram.com if
you want to send email
or you can just respond on uh chat on
whatever platform you're using
and um
thanks very much for lots of interesting
questions today we will save the ones
that i haven't gotten to up for another
time so
um
and uh
look forward to
talking with you another time